Can I stock taking the aroma clear when I start taking the aroma taste inhibitor medication? So aroma clear
Sounds like aroma taste, right? So it's an aroma taste inhibitor supplement that has dim and and
A few other things in it that help
All bad astrogens out of your body. So it's meant to be a
Quote-unquote substitute for an aroma taste inhibitor medication
So if you're on an aroma taste inhibitor medication, do you need to take dim or aroma clear or
you know other
natural aroma taste inhibitors?
No, you don't
You I mean the
Medication that's gonna pull your hormones, your astrogens out of your body is gonna far exceed what
The nutritional approach will do
That's why people like the nutritional approach
But you certainly don't need to spend money taking the aroma clear if you're gonna be on the aroma taste inhibitor medication
Then just put it in the fridge and save it for when and if you ever go off of that